[Music]
but we do have a very special guest with
us today Carolyn and Kindle bets to talk
about something very exciting that is
coming soon to st. Louis
she's with Marie's yes is Lady the
president of Enterprise Holdings
foundation and Carolyn Kindle I see the
Kindle you got money in kinder nope I
wish they use my name before I could
stop them you often get asked this
question yes they're like did you invite
that do it did you invent the reader and
always I say I wish cool well you got
some other big news that you want to
report on and it's big news for the st.
Louis area involving a new stadium yes
well a week ago today st. Louis was
awarded the 28th MLS franchise so been a
big big big week still lots to do but a
lot of celebration as well and we're
bringing it up because somehow you're
connected tell us about that I am strong
a third generation tailor so my
grandfather Jack see tailor founded
Enterprise Holdings so we own enterprise
national and Alamo car rental brands and
how is that related to soccer so there's
so that this team will be 100% locally
owned so the Jim Cavanaugh family so
co-founder of world wide technologies
and the Taylor family for Enterprise
Holdings we see pictures there
everybody's happy about soccer coming to
st. Louis that's going to have a big
effect on this area busts amazing I know
you guys lost football I'm still
smarting about that but now the actual
real football comes to town as they say
overseas as they call soccer football
what's the effect is gonna have in the
area exactly well first and foremost
were the first female majority lead
ownership team in the MLS so that was
another exciting you know cap in our
feather to celebrate but more
importantly we're back to being a three
professional sports team but it also
puts us on the international map and
that's where we think that enterprise
that st. Louis should be is that
International Maps so we're looking
forward to more tourism hopefully more
revenues and more international
businesses to notice Saint Louis and
move their businesses and their families
here well we've had that same kind of
movement happen in check well maybe not
the exact same kind of movement
happening in chess but we do have an
international crowd here as well what's
the connection between soccer and chess
well I think first and foremost you said
it they're both international games
played all over the globe but from what
little my chest career was there is a
lot of you know tactics and attacks and
defense and so if you think about a
soccer coach and his team they have to
prepare for the game make sure that they
handle their competitor strengths
exploit the weaknesses but then also
throughout the match they might have to
make quick changes to make sure they
maintain that competitive advantage they
sound like a chess player do you play
chess I played for one month my senior
year of high school I had a friend try
to teach me and I played for one month
it was at it was a very it was fun but I
just I just didn't quite pick it up as
well as I probably could have well you
know Jen always reminds us there's a
ladies night here in the club every
Thursday there's cheese and wine and it
might be the time they come back out and
then hang out I will certainly have to
check it out absolutely and Rex will be
happy to play you as well and you could
beat Rex I hope so maybe Jeanne will be
at ladies night ladies night but I mean
just in addition to ladies night that
she'll she'll be able to practice with
the rice tell me what's what's more for
beyond this as far as the future of
major league soccer and st. Louis what
what are the future plans sure well we
have a lot to do we have to build the
stadium so a beautiful stadium there was
that was just a mock-up it was so we're
getting really excited because we're
hopefully gonna have a more refined
version that we can share publicly or in
the next couple weeks we've got to work
on our corporate sponsorships really
team logistics but we've got to keep our
fans engaged and excite
because you know our first kick will
hopefully be in 2022 so we've got a
little bit of time but we just want to
make sure we continue to elevate the
excitement here in st. Louis very and in
downtown must be revitalization of the
area as well absolutely
so right now there's about eight billion
dollars committed towards renovations
billion yes hmm
tech startup districts and so we're
excited that our stadium will sit in
downtown West and will be a part of that
revitalization and we don't have to
change jobs guys I do some commentary
can I get out some love for commentating
and soccer and I thought I know much
about it but you know I mean I can I can
learn hey I'm learning soccer too even
join with me there we go you got a
commitment there guys you got it on
camera I might be skipping this job a
little bit nobody was there no I'm
staying with the chess of course thank
you so much for joining us continue the
great work Carolyn can Kindle bets
feeling right Carolyn yes Kindle bets
Major League Soccer coming to st. Louis
in addition to all the great chess
things it's amazing what the city
continues to do as it grows and expands
and attracts attention from the rest of
the world
[Music]